good morning Hank it's Friday January
21st 2011 I want to continue our
discussion about how the truth resists
simplicity by talking about narrative
complexity but in order to do that I
need to talk about my favorite person me
okay so the biggest award in young adult
literature is called the Prince award
which looks like this on a book and
looks like this in a basement and the
single most important moment of my whole
professional life happened five years
ago almost to the day when I received
the call saying that Looking for Alaska
my first novel had won the Prince award
and it was especially meaningful to me
because my first job after college was
as a temp at the magazine book list and
on my first day at book list I had to
re-type that's how old I am all these
speeches that were given at the first
Prince award reception and that is a
good narrative right you start out with
this 22-year old professional data
interest who writes a novel for years
and years at night and on the weekends
and then eventually it comes out and he
wins the very award that he used to type
the speeches for and you can imagine
this young writer working in isolation
and getting rejected over and over and
over again until a publisher takes a
chance on him but Hank the actual story
of how this book came to exist and have
this shiny piece of gold on it is
different and more complicated so I
thought I would try to tell that story
today so I did write this story at night
and on the weekends for three years but
I had constant help from my friend Ilene
Cooper who was one of my bosses at
Booklist and who's also an author
Eileen probably read and commented on
like a dozen drafts of Looking for
Alaska which by the way it wasn't even
called Looking for Alaska until my
friend cure Graf came up with that title
then once eileen was happy and I'd paid
cures $2 for coming up with the title
Eileen and I sent it to penguin and they
agreed to publish it provided I've
revised extensively although I had no
idea about how extensively I would have
to revise it so this book for those of
you who haven't read it is about a guy
who memorizes the last words of famous
people and falls in love with a girl
named Alaska only when Fang would agreed
to buy the book it wasn't about a guy
who memorizes the last words of famous
people in fact a lot of what people
liked about the book from the great
perhaps to the labyrinth came out in
those revisions after I'd sold the book
to penguin so I got about four years
after I started I had a reasonably
finished manuscript although it would be
wrong to say that I wrote that book the
truth is that eileen wrote parts of it
and my editor julie strauss cable wrote
parts of it and my wife wrote parts of
it in fact all these people wrote at
least a little bit of Looking for Alaska
and I am grateful to each and every one
of those people although no they
cannot have any of my royalties we all
like this idea that a book is created by
a single person for a single reader
because it's a narrative that makes
sense but the truth resists that
simplicity is the great Carl Sagan said
if you wish to make an apple pie from
scratch you must first invent the
universe so all these people work
together to make a book it came out
twelve people in a room decided it
should win this award and I was really
happy and then a little part of me was
like so what what I eventually realized
is that the real business of books is
not done by awards committees or people
who turn trees into paper or editors or
agents or even writers we're all just
facilitators the real business is done
by readers and the Looking for Alaska
that you read is not quite like the
Looking for Alaska that anyone else
reads the hundreds of thousands of
Looking for Alaska Reader stories are
not something I can hold in my hand or
even get my head around but Hank I do
want to say to you and to all the
nerdfighters you've read my books that
being able to participate in big
interesting conversations with you
through stories like this one and my
other books is really the most
fulfilling thing about my life
just kidding it's Henry and Sarah but
you guys are great too seriously if I
didn't have such a cute kid and a great
wife you would be the top well pizza it
goes serán Henry pizza the rest of my
family
nerdfighteria the mountain goats that's
my top five Hank I am freedom and Panem
and I will see you on Friday
it is Friday I'm so good at that